foreign
ladies and gentlemen the time has come
I've got to talk about this new Drake
album honestly never mind
I knew as soon as I heard this thing
that I'd have to give a longer take on
it because I like it and I knew a lot of
people weren't going to like it I know
it's been roundly clowned by both
critics and fans alike but yeah for some
reason this one really stuck out to me
in a good way very early on I tweeted
something along the lines of this being
an album of the ear Contender and the
reality is that holds up for me but I
owe you guys an explanation as to why
that is in order for me to make this
video and to tell this story I have to
start at the top I have to tell you I'm
kind of a drake fan or at least I was
but let's start at the beginning
you know a lot of girls be so back in
the day my introduction to Drake would
have been some Young Money singles that
came out like Bedrock you guys remember
Bedrock oh that was your girl I thought
I recognized it it's a goofy song with a
goofy Drake feature but that's where
this guy kind of began it was that and
it was also best I ever had was another
big Drake single back in the day not too
long after those singles I had an older
cousin that was telling me hey you got
to check out this new Drake song He's
got an album coming out you're gonna
love it and he showed me find your love
this was before thank me later came out
I really dug it and I was excited and
that was maybe as far as my life's
concerned one of the first albums that I
was ever anticipating before it came out
and then it came out and I loved that
album and that CD was actually one that
I had in my car when I first got a car
so it was one that I drove around
listening to all the time and if you've
got CDs like that in your car you
understand the significance that an
album like that's gonna hold in your
life not too long after that one was
take care which many regard as one of
his best if not not his best album and
then a couple years after that was
Nothing Was the Same which for me this
was like the height of Drake I was
enjoying all three of these albums he
was really establishing a signature
sound and each of the albums held
personal significance where I listened
to them in certain contexts and I can
always think back on those albums to
remind me of those times and places
where I heard them it's a really cool
experience that you can have with a lot
of different music and for me yeah it
was Drake it's important to understand
at this time when these albums were
coming out I wasn't really A hip-hop
head that didn't really happen until
about 2013. so it would have been around
the time or after that after Nothing Was
the Same came out but prior to Drake I
wasn't really listening to a whole lot
of hip-hop anyway those three albums
were great for me but then 2015 happened
this is where things might get a little
controversial because he puts out a
mixtape if you're reading this it's too
late I believe that was on Valentine's
Day of 2015. and to this day a lot of
people say that is Drake's best album I
don't know what they're talking about I
think it's one of my least favorite it's
one of the least interesting Drake
albums for me personally I understand
what he's doing and of course there are
a few hits on there but the reality is
that Drake kind of shed his signature
style in order to sound like a lot of
other rappers you could plug a lot of
different rappers into that album and it
would still make sense and that's part
of the problem for me it was an identity
crisis for Drake not only that but there
are songs on the album that are back to
back and sound almost identical the two
in question which I encourage you to
kind of play on top of each other 10
bands and energy have almost an
identical beat and they're back to back
on the album
and that in itself felt like a betrayal
because I was like what are we doing
here why is this how are you how can you
put this out how can you give us this
you know coming from a guy who had
like pretty good rap hits and good pop
hits I was just very disappointed with
that project yeah it was Drake in all
rap mode but he wasn't really rapping at
his highest level and he didn't sound
like himself and that to me was
frustrating also in 2015 he does a
collaborative project with future what a
time to be alive again not one that
really connected with me I still am not
a huge fan of future but I can respect a
few songs on there as well
[Music]
to me though that project has the same
problem that if you're reading this it's
too late had which was that it's Drake
trying to fit into some other rapper's
Lane and that one we're able to point to
Future and say he's trying to do the
future stuff it's not like he's sounding
like future but again it's just not
Drake's style
[Music]
this is obviously the part of the video
that I think a lot of people are going
to disagree with and I just have to
point out here that I'm not a fan of the
same Drake that a lot of people are a
fan of
because the world was on board with both
of these projects and a lot of people
still regard them very highly but it's
just not the kind of Drake that I like
it's not the kind of Drake that I enjoy
I told you I like the first three albums
but if you want another picture of the
Drake I enjoyed look at 2016. he
releases views he uses one of the first
albums as far as I can remember where he
kind of received lukewarm reception from
both critics and fans this was also
right around the time that the streaming
era was starting where people were
moving away from physical purchases and
everything was either Spotify or apple
music but in my opinion views elevated
Drake once again to his own sort of
sound or style now you may be thinking
is it really Drake's style because he's
doing this strange Patois and the
Jamaican accent all over this album
and you are correct and it doesn't sound
entirely authentic but I'm telling you
this project has some of the most
balanced music we've heard from Drake
some seriously good pop and Dancy hits
and some genuinely pretty good rap songs
I said this in my review of the album
that if you remove about four tracks
from this it becomes one of his best
albums I stand by that I think I replay
views more than any other Drake album of
course I replay it minus the four songs
and I don't know if I want to get into
and give you guys the sauce and tell you
which for I can give you a hint you're
gonna for sure cut out hotline bling
because it's a bonus track that doesn't
belong the broader Point here is that I
loved views but the big problem I had
with it was that it was too long and it
turns out that that problem would
persist with Drake albums moving into
the future the next few big albums that
we get from Drake more life scorpion
certified lover boy I don't even like
saying that one those albums are all
bloated they're all too long and not
just in the sense of oh I don't want to
listen to it for that long no none of
those albums can fit on a CD because
they exceed the maximum capacity for a
CD which is a little under 80 minutes
guy nobody needs an album that long I
could maybe see doing a huge album like
that if you had a lot to say but Drake
does not have a whole lot to say that's
not why we listen to Drake Drake might
be the only rapper that we can rely on
to talk about texting on every other
song My Side girl got a 5s with the
screen cracked still hit me back right
away as soon as you see the text reply
me all that gray in our conversation
history oh Tesco green is a little
different I truly do think that should
be some kind of drinking game or
something as you listen to a new Drake
album anytime he mentions anything about
texting or an iPhone you got to take a
shot so he puts out all three of these
bloated albums and in between there we
have a couple other things like care
package and darkland demo tapes across
all of these projects there are flashes
of Brilliance and I use the term
Brilliance a little Loosely here but
there are flashes of really good music
during this era of the bloated album
from Drake he's still making good music
here and there you know he puts out
these single packs every now and then I
feel like I always find at least one
song that's really good and that's where
some of his best work as a rapper comes
out
if you need some illustrations go listen
to diplomatic immunity or omerta those
songs are fantastic that's the kind of
Rapid Drake that I would love to hear a
full album from Drake's become a very
corny character he's always been a bit
of a meme with the Draco type of guy
jokes but then he becomes an even bigger
meme on Tick Tock about all this sort of
cartoon character behaviors that he
engages in or that we like to think he
does
[Music]
come on
anytime we hear some cartoony beat we
think oh don't let Drake get hold of
this he's just a goofy dude and I don't
like I don't want to get into too much
of it but whether it's texting Millie
Bobby Brown or braiding the Nike symbol
into his hair Drake's Just he's just
Drake there's nobody quite like him and
he's he's a strange guy he's a very
dominant musician and there's no denying
the accolades that he's achieved but
he's goofy like that
he's goofy like that and his music is
kind of perpetually immature which for
the most part doesn't really matter
because it's just fun to listen to but
I've reached a point in my life where I
don't expect a whole lot from Drake I
would love for him to turn the
rapability dial up to 10 and give us a
full project like that but you know
we'll have to see if that ever shows up
so earlier this year Drake reveals the
album cover for his newest album
honestly never mind it's sort of this
metal font washed out and I'm thinking
to myself wow are we finally gonna get
the rap album from Drake that I've been
thinking about for years I remember
saying you know based on this cover I
feel like it's either going to be this
big rap album or he's going to lean
fully into the dance hall stuff
so we end up getting the full dance
record it's not really dance hall Styles
it's more of electronic house type music
it's very low-key house music it's more
about setting a Vibe than it is lighting
up the club though there are a couple of
tracks that I could see lighting up the
club so after you know listening to this
album The First Time second time third
time I found myself liking pretty much
every song the one that I don't like
even to this day is Currents which
features the squeaky bed spring sound
sort of an or type of
foreign
don't put that in I don't want people
sampling that listen I understand it's a
reference to some old Jersey beat or
whatever but that doesn't make it
enjoyable for me that doesn't mean it
doesn't hurt my ears I don't want to
hear that as a song
the song other than that is decent but
yeah that one is the closest there is to
a skip on here for me falling back is
interesting because the beat is
phenomenal I love the way that beat
comes in
hey but Drake just kind of sings very
strange over that song for quite a long
time I don't know if he's aware that
he's not quite hitting the notes
um I hope he is maybe he's doing it as a
bit like look I don't have to sing well
and you'll still listen to it
I don't I don't know maybe I don't have
to listen to it
there's plenty of other songs on here
that I enjoy more though one of my
personal favorites is massive now
massive is
well it is massive it feels like the
kind of song that would go off in the
club I don't wanna
it's still a bit low-key which is cool
but yeah it's a lot more energized than
most of the album towards the end you
know second to last track we get
liability which sounds like the old old
Drake when he used to be emulating
Houston Styles and then the album closes
with a 21 Savage feature and Drake
rapping mapping which is kind of cool to
see you know even though it breaks the
mold from the rest of the album it's not
a bad way to close it out in my opinion
so yeah the reception of this was very
mixed a lot of people were hating it
right off the bat and there's a lot of
you know hilarious memes out there about
this album
I don't think there's too many music
critics whether you're looking here on
YouTube or anywhere
that are gonna talk about this album as
being something amazing and look is it
the best dance record I've ever heard
absolutely not is it even objectively
good I don't know who am I to say that
what I can tell you though is that this
album accomplishes its goal for me which
is to kind of get me moving and to get
me enjoying myself like I like this I
like the mood that this album creates I
like that Drake decided to commit to a
style even if it's not a style that he
executed perfectly even if it's not a
style that a lot of his fans enjoy I
appreciate what it is and I enjoy the
style here Drake being somebody who for
years has put out these very long
bloated albums decides to give us
something that is short and mostly
consistent the lyrics might not be much
to write home about and kind of could be
consistent with most of his output but
it just feels like a significant
departure from what I'm used to from
Drake
and that's what I've been kind of hoping
for for years at this point chances are
if you don't like this album you either
aren't interested in the dance style
that he adopted here or if you are
interested in dance and house music you
just think this is a cheap imitation I
can't argue with that and I've seen a
lot of people love you the same
complaint against an album Like Jesus
from Kanye because they say this is just
a cheap imitation of a group like Death
Grips which could also be true for you
comparison can definitely kill an album
if you're hearing it it's just reminding
you of a better artist but this one
doesn't do that for me and I think it's
because of the style that he has here
because he's not trying to be the most
explosive dance record I to me it
doesn't feel quite as much of an
imitation at least for you know the
dance artists that I enjoy I'll be the
first to admit I'm probably not aware of
any artists who he may have ripped off
here or if you think he sounds exactly
like somebody else I'm probably just not
aware of that but I just appreciate the
album for what it is I think it's funny
that I wound up talking about Yeezus
here because some people wanted to call
this album Drake's uses I am going to
try my best to unpack that because it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
there's terms that get thrown around
with this album and some of them I think
are used incorrectly the first is
experimental this is not an experimental
album because Drake is exploring
existing genres of music
it might be new to him but it's
certainly not new I do think the album
is a risk though while it's not
experimental it is a risk because it is
Drake departing from styles that he
knows well and that he knows will
perform well for him so it is a risk but
it's not experimental music I don't
think Drake's trying to redefine any
genres of music with this one if I were
to compare this album to anything I
would call this Drake's honestly never
mind because that's well that's what it
is and that's a cheap shot for me at the
end of the day I am the type of person
that likes to see artists taking risks
especially when it's an artist as big as
someone like Drake a lot of artists
reach a certain level of fame or
accomplishment and they can kind of
Coast right they can just let off the
brakes and just kind of put out the same
thing or some variation of the same
thing over and over and people are going
to eat it up you know we love that
artist for who they are people love
consuming new Drake albums even if they
sound pretty much the same throughout
and he doesn't have a whole lot of new
stuff to offer us I think communities
have more critically minded listeners
will tell you that albums like Scorpion
or clb are not very good but the numbers
suggest otherwise because the average
listener just wants to hear Drake they
don't really care what he's singing
about
I think the average listener probably
enjoys 2C slide that average listener is
not me I do not like that song I do not
want to hear it ever again but for an
artist as big as Drake to decide to make
something completely different and to
try his hand at something completely
different is very exciting to me
and maybe the title is kind of
suggesting that maybe he was aware that
this was a risk I'm sure he was maybe he
was aware that a lot of his fans weren't
going to enjoy it and the title suggest
that it's kind of a throwaway kind of a
one-off you know honestly never mind you
guys can just listen to this if you
don't like it oh well like there will be
another album coming from me that'll
sound like everything else but I think
you should own it a little more I don't
think you should be embarrassed to this
I think there's a lot of critics and
people that would disagree with me on
that but I like what he did here I don't
think I'm the only person to feel that
way maybe I'm in the minority that's
fine but like I said I appreciate
artists taking risks when they have that
big of a platform because Drake is
somebody who you know like the banks in
08 is just too big to fail there's not
much he could do that would hurt his
career
[Music]
even an album like this I mean yeah it
might be a little speed bump maybe not a
lot of people enjoy it but I guarantee
you the next album he puts out that
sounds like clb is going to perform just
as well as clb did
and it'll probably be just as boring for
someone like me there's another big
artist out there who took a big risk
this year making a dance album and that
artist's name is Beyonce Beyonce's album
was much better received than Drake's
probably because it's Beyonce but also
because she put a lot into that one the
level of energy on that is much higher
than it is on Drake's but man I don't
know you asked me I kind of prefer the
chill Vibe of Drake's album I cannot say
and will not say that it is better than
Beyonce's because that will probably get
me murdered but I can say that I
personally enjoy it more and I'm gonna
find myself returning to it more than I
will Renaissance I really the last thing
I need right now is the Beehive stinging
me okay please please have mercy alright
so here we are final thoughts on this
album I like I said for me this is an
album of the Year Contender what does
that mean it doesn't mean it's number
one I've already told you what my number
one is it's Mr morale and the big
steppers from Kendrick Lamar however
album of the Year Contender for me means
this is most likely going to make my top
10 by the end of the year as stands
right now I think it's probably in the
top five I don't know exactly where I'd
have to sit down and figure that out but
it's up there and I'm still enjoying it
and if you want to go out and give it
another listen maybe you didn't like it
the first time around just put it on
while you're hanging out maybe in a hot
tub I listen to this album in a hot tub
it was great if you don't have a hot tub
maybe draw a bath
do people draw baths anymore that's
about all I have for today but as always
thank you for listening and whether it's
10 seconds or 10 minutes you know I'll
see you on the next video
I did the toughest actor follows back